dawn breaks on the fishing waters of
lampadusa and with it
a distant outline
it's a small boat packed with people
the italian border police have seen the
boat and are on their way on board there
are 12 migrants young men who wave and
offer victory salutes
they've come from tunisia
the police follow their boat and they
send over a couple of officers in a
rigid inflatable to guide the migrants
towards the port
and this is why lampedusa is so
important in the story of migration
those people have traveled in that boat
from tunisia about 80 miles away and
when they land on this island they'll be
in the european union
the migrants arrive in harbour they're
kept on board for a while details are
taken
but eventually
they step off
they're given medical tests and then
taken away in vans
and this is where they go
an overcrowded detention center
that looks a lot like a prison
sangare had arrived the previous night
she told us she'd escaped abuse in ivory
coast
and had come here on a packed boat from
tunisia
[Music]
[Music]
the dark is often used as cover
smugglers can transfer migrants from
large ships onto much smaller boats
making them harder to spot
on the night we went out police and
coast guard were looking for seven
different vessels they do pursue
smugglers but mostly their job is about
search and rescue
and it is relentless
the morning brings more evidence of
migrant arrivals
the waters around lampadusa are dotted
with these
abandoned vessels
littered with food and rubbish
the skipper of our boat removes fuel
from them as a safety measure
this the debris left by desperate people
making dangerous journeys
and those voyages start here on the
tunisian coast itself a seascape of
discarded wrecks
this whole area is a center for the
lucrative business of people smuggling
migrants come here to offer cash they
often can't afford in return for the
chance of getting to europe
the money goes to people like ali he's
26 a people smuggler wanted for
trafficking migrants across the water
from tunisia to lampedusa he is
unapologetic and apparently unafraid
a dangerous combination
of
it's a whole industry and at the heart
of it are the middlemen
this man claims he is careful but that
others are simply greedy and callous
[Music]
[Music]
do die in vast numbers bodies wash up
along the tunisian coastline nameless
and often forgotten
this dusty strip of land is now a
cemetery for migrants who didn't survive
the journey
um
more than a thousand people have already
died this year trying to navigate this
particular sea crossing
but still they come
back in lampedusa there are more rusting
reminders
this decrepit old trawler arrived
recently with nearly 500 crammed aboard
for those wanting a new life this island
has a magnetic attraction and the flow
of people
isn't going to stop adam parsons sky
news lampedusa